nobody wins oh every movie about Alcala
know me it's so sad yeah no I never
shows up sights
hi I'm Robert Eggers and I'm Robert
Pattinson and this is our scene
breakdown or the lighthouse
I think it just water but we were
drinking it though I mean there was and
I was actually one of well I'm stalking
us the other day like that kind of it's
hard to do there are your litter you
Connie felt disgusting afters and then
it's kind of and we did like four takes
of that yeah it's really really
difficult to spoil them with it but very
pronounced gag reflex yeah you guys yeah
I mean there was like a very specific
time we were supposed to be doing
would you can sort of see Willam thing I
should know I guess like I had a
different done my red eyes I had a kind
of a lumberjack dance yeah but you but
you I mean you're doing all the moves
around the table was yeah yeah I feel
like because my characters so contained
constricted and kind of the earlier in
his sobriety I kind of wanted to get it
wasn't just like when he got drunk with
well while I was drinking the whole time
it wasn't it wasn't like they would end
up on the same level
yeah yeah way Bo it's not like it's fun
to hang out with him it's literally like
it's like and then when he gets sort of
tender with him later and when he's kind
of tired and drunk and it's even more
than it's like he could just never they
can never quite get on the same page but
I think that's kind of what I was yeah
that makes total sense yeah and then and
because they're the you know generally
things are so tamp down and here the
dancing and the drinking is just like
revenue and 110
[Music]
and he's been looking for
Willems validation the whole movie and
it's kind of as soon as he's getting his
attention focus it's lit check you know
he's been wanting a pat on the head so
long as soon as he gets the attention of
them it's like a hyperactive child they
were just kind of you just like it's too
Polly Clooney's your mind and yeah yeah
and you're definitely like you know
trying to outdo his J or lumberjack
dance by the way you can't see Rob's
feet but the dancies Jake is incredibly
complicated
Robert flatly would be very honest I
think that's there anytime about every
success would be managed to do a spin
yeah whenever Willem Dafoe's shouts dad
say is it different like normally if
someone said you might have a done
[Music]
yeah this is one of my favorite
performances of yours I think Rob often
surprised me this is one of these
moments where he went further than
further than I expected but also
slightly different than how I what I
might my preconceived notions about
about the character in the end of this
clip when you when you seem like you're
speaking in tongues like everyone in
like the entire crew was like shocked
and it's it's one of the most memorable
moments in the film for me Rob is
singing I mean is he is singing lyrics
here like if you watch this with
subtitles like this is a lumberjack song
it's kind of Hawkes I knew it was it
said it was in the script it was like it
was he's speeding up and speeding up and
speeding up I think that's like that's
like three verses of the song yeah yeah
and the recording that you had is like a
trillion times slower yeah and you're
doing like this scene shows you you are
so extreme but then this is this is
right before this is it very is a
montage of masturbating with lots of or
imagery and severed head was ill-advised
and and my brother and and jaren
Blaschke the brother who wrote this with
me and Jerry baccha the GP we were like
okay so this dancing scene needs to be
scarier than like a severed head and I
think I think you nailed it
[Music]
there's hardly any movie a many
characters or any character arcs where
you can have that sustained height and
desperation for a half a movie being
absolutely obliterated drive inside and
how many movies that gonna come out I
died again thanks for watching I've seen
breakdown and be sure to check out the
night houses in theaters right now and
buy your tickets on Fandango